this video is brought to you by
nordvpn give yourself options
online go to nordvpn.com forward slash bio
to get a two-year plan with a huge discount
plus a bonus month more on them in just a bit
it has been over 50 years since a man known only
as bible john terrorized the scottish city of
glasgow with a two-year-long killing spree the
club known as the barolan ballroom was exclusive
hunting ground he picked up women danced with them
and when the night was done he would take them
home and strangle them just meters from the safety
of said home his crimes were followed by the
largest police operation in the history of glasgow
over 100 detectives worked the case collecting
over 50 000 statements and questioning 5 000
suspects trying to identify the killer all of this
proved to be in vain bible john simply disappeared
once his murder spree had ended never to be heard
from again who he was why he did what he did
and why he stopped remain mysteries to this day
the year was 1968 in glasgow scotland patricia
docker was a 25 year old auxiliary nurse who had
taken a young son and moved in with her parents
while her husband was stationed at the royal air
force base near digby in lincolnshire england on
february 22nd patricia decided that she wanted
to let her hair down a little things weren't going
too well for her her relationship with her husband
was on the rocks and the couple had already talked
about getting a divorce their job got pretty
intense as pat worked night shifts at one of the
busiest hospitals in the city that was why for one
night she wanted to put all of her problems aside
and enjoy some me time that thursday evening pat
had the day off so she left her four-year-old son
in the care of his grandparents she dressed up in
one of her most fashionable outfits a yellow
mini dress accessorized with a brown handbag
to match her shoes all of this was covered by
a large duffle coat with a fur collar fashion
is nice and all that but this is still a winter's
night in scotland once she was ready pat hit the
town for a night of dancing drinking and maybe
even some casual flirting little did she know that
she would become involved in the largest manhunt
in the city's history back then if you were young
and you were looking for a good time in glasgow
you went to the majestic that's where pat's
parents thought she was going but it was not where
she actually went she might have stopped there
originally but for reasons that remain unknown
she ended up at the barrel and ballroom which was
hosting an over 25s night one dancehall is as good
as another right well unfortunately for patricia
docker this dance hall was the hunting grounds
for a violent predator and he was there that night
looking for prey munchie was inside the dancehall
it becomes pretty much impossible to track pat's
movements as she became just another figure in
the crowd vibing to the sounds of the swinging
60s she said hello to a few friends danced with a
few people had a few drinks what you would expect
to happen on a night out but at one point she
did meet a man he was in his mid to late 20s
well groomed with either reddish or light brown
hair and handsome enough to catch pat's attention
the two talked a little danced a little and they
left maryland together that was the last time that
anyone saw patricia docker alive the following
morning a tablet maker named maurice goodman left
his house and was walking the short journey
to the lock-up garage where he kept his car
when he suddenly came across a ghastly sight
that would haunt him forever it was the body of
patricia docker partially naked beaten and bruised
lying in the doorway of the garage goodman rushed
to call the cops and two detectives were soon on
the scene the police pathologist arrived shortly
after them and provided the first clues of the
investigation based on rigor mortis pat had been
murdered hours earlier most likely a short time
after leaving the barylan ballroom she had been
hit in the face and head mercilessly although none
of these injuries would have been life threatening
instead she was killed by strangulation most
likely with a belt or pantyhose the murder weapon
was never recovered and neither were the rest of
pat's clothes the medical examiner noted that pat
docker was menstruating at the time of her death
although no importance was placed on that fact
yet police began canvassing the neighborhood but
did not turn up any useful leads one neighbor
thought that they had a cry for help during
the early hours of the morning but they didn't
bother to get up and check so that was a dead end
police did id the body pretty fast does one of the
ambulance men recognize pat as a nurse who worked
at the mernskirk hospital her parents were alerted
to the tragedy and her father made the official
identification from then on it was slim pickings
for investigators the time they saved with the id
they lost by making inquiries the majestic since
that was where they thought patricia docker
went that night eventually they found out that
she ended up at the barylan ballroom instead and
that she left with a young man who was most likely
her killer but that was about it nobody seemed
to remember anything remarkable about him and
those who did might not have been too eager to
talk you see the maryland was the kind of place
where many guests took off their wedding rings by
accident and forgot that they were married for a
few hours which could potentially explain why pat
docker and probably many others preferred to tell
their loved ones that they went somewhere else
to spend their evening truth be told the crime
might not have been the police's highest priority
at the time glasgow was quite a violent place back
then with a murder rate there was over double that
of other big cities like edinburgh london police
thought this was a straightforward and isolated
crime of passion a man picked up a woman at a club
and when she rebuffed his advances he attacked her
they did not yet know that they were investigating
the first murder of the man who had become known
as scotland's most notorious unidentified killer
so when leads dried up they moved on to
another case that is until he struck again
almost a year and a half passed before the
killer claimed another victim by this point
most of glasgow had quietly forgotten about
the murder of patricia docker and nobody
suspected that the city had a vicious serial
killer in its midst but then on august 16
1969 a familiar scenario occurred to remind
everyone of the dangers that lurked within
the shadows of glasgow jemima mcdonald
was a 32 year old mother of three who
liked to let loose every now and then just
like pat dawker when the time came for a
little carousing she left her children with her
sister and went to the maryland ballroom where
she was somewhat of a regular because of this
several people spotted her in the dance hall
that night and they also noticed that she was
getting very friendly with a guy whose description
matched that of pat docker's final companion a
tall man in his late twenties early thirties slim
build well dressed well groomed he was sporting a
blue suit and reddish hair winders also said that
he spoke with a glaswegian accent and overheard
him making several biblical references which would
ultimately end up giving him his unique moniker in
the press they even had a first name for him john
although it was most likely an alias it appeared
that jemima macdonald was quite infatuated with a
new consort and the two left baryland together
shortly after midnight the following morning
her sister margaret got worried when she saw
that jemima had not returned home that night
her worry soon turned to panic when she heard
the local scuttlebutt that some neighborhood
kids were going around telling everyone that they
discovered a dead body in an abandoned tenement
building just yards from her house margaret
went there to check if the rumor was true or
if kids were just being kids and her findings
confirmed her worst fear the body was real
and it belonged to her sister jeremiah macdonald
had been ferociously assaulted and then strangled
to death just like with patricia docker the body
was found close to her home and her handbag was
missing although unlike the first victim jemima
macdonald had not been stripped naked even though
the attack was eerily reminiscent of the one on
patricia docker the police were not quite ready to
attribute them both to the same culprit since two
different murderers frequenting the same nightclub
within a year and a half times ban would not have
been unheard of that being said they also didn't
rule out the possibility so they stepped up their
efforts to find him this time they sent undercover
officers to the dancehall they had one policewoman
dress up as jemima mcdonald and retrace her last
known steps to see if it jogged anyone's memory
they even released a sketch of the suspect to the
public which was a first for a scottish murder
investigation since back then these were only
circulating among police organizations all of
this effort turned up nothing police did not get
any closer towards catching their man although to
be fair the culprit did not wait around too long
before he killed again all right we'll get back
to our video in just a second but first here's
a word from today's video sponsor nordvpn
look everybody uses the internet slightly
differently and that's totally fine but you
don't want to do is use the internet unprotected
you may have heard me talk about what nordvpn can
do for you previously encrypt your internet data
and move your online activity to another location
with just a single click either for security
or streaming all that is still true nor vpn has
more than 5 000 servers throughout 60 countries
but vpns give you access to so much more than just
new tv shows like what if you want to buy a video
game that's cheaper somewhere else or maybe not
even available in your country well use nordvpn
having trouble connecting to social media nordvpn
want to root your connections through multiple
servers just for double layered security yes
totally possible with nordvpn right now as a
special deal you guys can get a two-year plan at
a huge discount plus one free month and if you
try nord and change your mind they offer a 30 day
money back guarantee all you've got to do is head
to nordvpn.com forward slash bio again nordvbn.com
forward slash bio for a two-year deal at a huge
discount plus a free month or just follow
the link below and now back to today's video
this time only a couple of months had passed
before the mysterious killer decided to paint
the town red once more it was october 31 1969
halloween night so unsurprisingly there were
quite a few parties taking place throughout
glasgow many people hit the town to celebrate
and among them was helen partook a 29 year old
mother of two her husband volunteered to stay
home with a kid so his wife could go out and enjoy
a night out although he was a bit apprehensive by
that point the idea that there was a killer among
them stalking the streets of glasgow at night put
some of the locals on edge but no need to worry
though helen reassured her husband she was going
out accompanied by her sister jean and the
two of them would look after each other so
with that mata settled helen got dressed up and
went out her destination the maryland ballroom
according to jean she and helen paired off with
two men who both introduced themselves as john and
spent most of the night dancing with them when it
was time to go all four of them left together the
harmless john traveled on foot to a nearby bus
station while the sisters and the evil john got
into a taxi together the following experience was
either innocuous or sinister depending on who you
ask i mean in hindsight it was absolutely sinister
the two sisters were sharing a ride with a serial
killer after all but according to one book on
the subject that three of them spent the time
mostly talking about trivial things and when gene
was the first to reach her destination she felt
like she was leaving helen in safe hands another
book however paints a much darker picture and says
that john was morose even upset during the whole
trip resenting gene's presence he spent the time
talking about the evils of dens of iniquity such
as the parallel ballroom and chastised the women
of loose morals who frequented such places even
so john's off-putting behavior wasn't enough
to raise any serious alarm bells so when gene
got out of the cab and waved goodbye to helen
she had no idea that that would be the last time
she'd see her sister alive helen puddik's body
was found the next morning by a man walking his
dog she had been dumped in a courtyard once again
close to where she lived she had been strangled
her clothes had been ripped and her handbag had
been taken like the previous two victims helen was
menstruating at the time of her death police had
noticed this with the other women but thought
it was simply a coincidence now however the
killer took time to make a clear reference to
this fact by taking one of her sanitary pads
and placing it under her armpit could it be
that this was some kind of trigger for him that
unleashed his murderous rage that wasn't the only
difference between the crime scenes there were a
few other signs that as the killings continued
the culprit was starting to get either more
careless or was losing his ability to control
his violent urges he left a deep bite mark on
helen's body and also a semen stain on her clothes
nowadays those would be viable forensic clues but
it was still the 1960s so there wasn't a lot
that the police could do with them even so the
investigators preserved the evidence in the hopes
that it would become more useful in the future
with three murders of similar victims who were
all picked up in the same place most likely by
the same man there could be no more doubt glasgow
had a serial killer on his hands the press picked
up on the murderer's habit of quoting scripture
and gave him the notorious sobriquet bible john
that kicked the police investigation into high
gear and with all hands on deck everyone was
hopeful that bible john would soon be behind
bars after all he left plenty of witnesses
behind including helen's sister gene who had
spent a whole cab ride with him and there were
other people who spotted him at baryland as well
the official description provided by the police to
the press described bible john as a man of medium
build around six feet tall 25 to 30 years of age
with short light reddish hair and blue gray eyes
with one tooth in the upper right corner of the
mouth overlapping another tooth and sporting a
military military-style watch investigators even
circulated a detailed color portrait of the killer
made by an artist from the glasgow school of art
unsurprisingly the sketch opened the floodgates
and the tip started pouring in at torrential
speed over 4 000 people contacted the police
just in the days that followed claiming to know
someone who resembled the portrait eventually
investigators began issuing special cards to
the innocent men who had been questioned and
cleared of charges just so that they could
prove to their loved ones and co-workers that
they weren't bible john a profile compiled by
a psychiatrist in 1970 described john as a sex
killer appeared and acted like the sort of young
man that a mother would want her daughter to bring
home he was good at hiding his evil side from
those close to him and on the exterior he appeared
shy and harmless he was a loner who preferred solo
activities opting to go alone to the cinema over
going out with a group to drink or watch a game
he possessed many of the traits often found in
compulsive sex killers such as tidiness vanity
high intelligence effeminacy and a dislike of
smoking drinking and vulgar language he probably
still lived with his mother who saw him as nothing
but a sweet little boy even though he secretly
harbored a hatred of women which compelled him to
exert his power over them and ultimately murdered
them for a while there was this belief that the
killer attended clubs even when he didn't murder
anybody then on certain night something happened
that triggered his compulsion to kill therefore 16
officers were assigned to dance duty every night
they would go out undercover at the baryland and
other dancehalls and boogie until the wee hours of
the morning in the hopes that they might run into
bible john on the dance floor another strange lead
came from a witness who remembered having a casual
chat with a killer about golf where john mentioned
that his cousin had recently scored a hole in one
this was all the info the police had to go
on but they still reached out to all the
400-plus golf courses in scotland to see if anyone
remembered such a feat being celebrated recently
cabbies and bus drivers in glasgow were
all tracked down and questioned if they
recognized the portrait dentists were asked if
any of them could identify bible john based on
the overlapping tooth an appeal was made to the
armed forces since the killer's wristwatch and
short hairstyles suggested he could have been
a military man one by one each lead was pursued
and one by one each lead had a dead end although
at first police were hopeful that identifying and
catching bible john was only a matter of time
that hope was dwindling with every passing day
it's probably not much of a spoiler to tell
you that the police never caught bible john
the killer seemingly vanished after the murder
of helen potter and was never heard from again
he became a boogeyman a distant memory of terror
that once lurked in the shadow similar to other
notorious killers such as jack the ripper or the
zodiac but although the bible john murders became
a cold case it was never officially closed
obviously the 100 detectives who once worked
on the case were reassigned once the clues had
dried up but they still pursued new leads whenever
they appeared helen's sister jean still came in
whenever there was a new suspect to look at she
never publicly discussed her sister's murder but
she was available whenever the police needed her
gene made around 250 such trips to the station but
none of them ever ended with her pointing a finger
at a suspect and saying that's him that's the man
that killed my sister there was some renewed zeal
for the investigation during the 1990s when
dna analysis became the new forensic darling
glasgow police still had the semen samples from
the putting murder but the samples on their own
would be useless without something to match them
up against police wanted to test dna from one of
their strongest suspects a man known back then as
simply john m who had committed suicide in 1980.
he seemed like a good fit he had a very strong
resemblance to the bible john sketch and he used
to serve in the armed forces as part of the scots
guard as the investigation continued through the
years he kept popping up on top of the suspect
pile so in 1996 the police obtained an exclamation
order for his body the operation was supposed to
be discreet but the name of the suspect leaked
out and all of a sudden the scottish press were
all over it deeming john mcinnes to be bible john
before the results even came in on top of that the
police were pressured to justify why exactly the
exclamation and dna test ended up costing over
a million dollars and overall the whole thing
turned into one big pr nightmare then the coup
de grace was delivered when the results came in
and they cleared john mcinnes of any involvement
leaving crown investigators with a lot of egg on
their faces as they issued a very prolonged and
public apology to the mcginnis family but the way
they bungled it so one of the main suspects in the
case was off the table but even worse the debacle
had caused the authorities to be a lot more
apprehensive about trying it again the sad reality
was that the murders of bible john had long been
replaced by newer even more horrifying crimes so
it was a matter of allocating resources where they
would be most effective that being said there were
rumblings around 2005 that glasgow police had
collected dna samples from a new family in order
to match them that time however their name didn't
get out since no public statements on the matter
were ever made we can only presume the results
were negative but let's get to the main event
peter tobin if you are familiar with the bible
john case at all then you know that name already
for the last 15 years or so he has been presented
by many people as the best candidate to be
bible john let's start with the obvious here peter
tobin is a convicted serial killer who murdered at
least three young women between 1991 and 2006 but
since he was already in his mid-40s by the time he
committed his first known murder police suspected
that there might be earlier victims thus operation
anagram was born in 2006 but the goal being to
track tobin's movements as far back as possible
to see if there were links to any previous murders
that's when the bible john connection popped
up since it was revealed that tobin lived near
glasgow at the time of the baryland killings and
would have been in his mid-20s he moved to england
the same year the murders stopped after marrying
for the first time furthermore tobin came from a
strict religious family and his first wife once
said that he attacked her after becoming enraged
because she was menstruating a lot of fingers
were starting to point in tobin's direction but
dna couldn't help us anymore by the time of his
arrest the samples from the 1960s became too
degraded to produce conclusive results to this
day plenty of people are still convinced that he
is bible john however the detectives who worked on
operation anagram are not among them and they say
that they've eliminated tobin as a suspect pretty
conclusively insisting that he wasn't in glasgow
at the time of some of the murders so for now
bible john remains as elusive as ever so i'm not
gonna ask if you enjoyed today's video but if you
enjoy this sort of crime content i actually
have a entire show dedicated to true crime
it's called the casual criminalist we do a full
extended super long episode all about bible john
which i'll link to on the screen now you can
check out there'll be a link below as well
and well check it out please subscribe
if you like it and thank you for watching
you